i'm i'm more coming along to your
viewpoint of regulation i get i get more
as you keep talking i get more and more
what you're trying to get across
i just don't really understand how you
can
do it when
you've already got politicians brought
in and one thing that i know about
politicians is that when they double
down on something
they'll never
they'll never get up their ground
because it makes them look weak as
politicians and if the politician admits
that they're wrong
their credibility falls through the
floor and that's what they're all afraid
of yeah it's so fickle
so when you've got like the people in
this country you mentioned prisons you
had during the leadership campaign for
the labour leader when jeremy corbyn
stepped down you had um lisa nandy i
believe go and do a a rally somewhere
and said that if a biological man
transgender woman was convicted of rape
would you let that person go into a
female jail and she's great and she said
rape grape my apologies no problem she
said she said yeah yeah i'll put them in
they can go in a female prison now i
shared something on my instagram a
little while ago i think it was american
news but it's still relevant it can
happen here
um
where a man a biological man as a
transgender woman went to prison
had lots of illegal fun yeah and and got
two people pregnant exactly that yeah
exactly though yeah and got two people
pregnant
so i think it does take strong
individuals to go do you know what we've
had enough of this but you're not going
to get that from the political class
because otherwise
system does not make sense as we were
talking about earlier
young people under the age of
in in england under age of 18 cannot
vote you're suing 10 to 14 year olds
for making certain decisions labeling as
sexual harassment but they can't make
other decisions yeah by the way legally
i don't think they're suing the the
children i i know i know but i'm saying
how it's for the decisions of their
children but they aren't legally allowed
to make decisions themselves so how how
is that making sense
and how is it
that sexual harassment right when
there's nothing sexual that has to do
with it that's what's blowing my mind
how can you classify something so that's
the question that does transgenderism
bring in a sexual element
like identity
is identity i'm a man there's no sexual
element in there
so why does transgender have a sexual
element
because there's no nobody's regulating
it everybody's just accepting what it is
not to
offend them essentially they're just
this culture nowadays has become
upset oh goodness can't talk
like how do you say it i can't say a
sexual element no no except accept it
goodness i couldn't say that yes
accepting
of
just things that have this culture
nowadays as nobody's like questioning it
logically that's just like oh you say
that sexual harassment against you
because they got their prone because
they got your pronouns wrong okay yes it
is we don't want to offend you anymore
we don't want anything come against us
so we're going to take your word for it
instead of logically thinking about it
that's not sexual harassment they just
forgot how to say your pronouns
correctly they probably forgot what they
ate for breakfast this morning yeah i
think it's conflation of the grouping
you know earlier on i said lgbt yeah
the lgb part is sexual the t part isn't
yeah and i think you have the conflation
there yeah it's true so i think that's
probably where you get that but it's
it's completely backwards but that's the
way i'm can we also
non-binary because where does non-binary
come into all of this i don't really
understand how that works how can you
not
be agenda
because you feel that way because i
remember watching a thing on british
news and on british tv about when piers
morgan was on there and he was talking
about there was a guy and i said there
are there are a hundred genders
have you guys seen a video there were
100 genders and some of them were like
wisp gender and
you feel wispily and
whatever it was right and piers was like
stop the [ __ ]
you know basically it's like stop the bs
so like i said going back to what was
saying earlier on is it this thing is a
feeling
and my whole thing is when did feelings
start to trump factual information
like because i always said when when
when does a transgender stop because
um the trans train stopped because
there's a guy in um
holland a couple of years ago called
emil rattleband right
and emil rattleband
was a 70 year old man
and he said he felt more in his 40s
and then he said he wanted to transit he
wanted to be quote-unquote trans age and
he went to court he lost the case by the
way
but the fact that he said he wanted to
be younger
than his actual age to me now says
there's now going to be in the future an
argument for people wanting to be
a different age where do we draw the
line and that's what i said so imagine
now
there's a man who says
so say they say trans age is a thing now
you can identify someone younger
if a man identifies as younger and a
child identifies as older
and they get into a relationship
now oh god there's an example now
pedophilia and homo
and now pedophilia and child molestation
doesn't even exist exactly if you think
this is a hyperbolic this has actually
happened there's a there's a man in
canada he's uh he was married with three
kids
and literally transitioned not only to a
uh to a woman to a little girl he
claimed up to five years old and was
adopted
by two parents it's actually on youtube
typing canada trans uh trans man child
on youtube oh for goodness sake what is
it where is where does the train stop
where does it stop where does it start
yeah where does it stop like
yeah
who's benefiting from it because i don't
understand how these regulations are all
the rules and accept it i don't
understand where it's coming from and
why it's being accepted
confusing what needs to happen there
needs to be a sort of a william wallace
sort of figure that's willing to take
all the accusations all the things
because i rather suffer for my future
generation to live in peace if it means
that i'm going to get all the flack i
need to get so be it but that was that
was peace
that was kevin samuels yeah yeah but
what needs to happen that's what
happened so there needs to be more
sacrificial lambs to see in this area
yeah
how would you get the platform for that
though
who would get the platform for that you
could create your own you question your
own criteria can you though you can't
you can't you can you can't but before
getting canceled or not there's there's
a world there's a way especially with
blockchain technology you know you can
that you don't have to um be on youtube
or anything you know decentralized
systems
even tonight's show you you pulled me up
for a word i shouldn't have used for the
for the algorithm right yeah
right in itself if you use that too many
times you're busted right yeah but
doesn't mean you have to be huge but
then you have places like ghetto yeah
you have places like if you built a
following here people like youtube they
might just watch this on youtube for the
convenience i like youtube more than
anything else but i'm on i'm on rumble i
think what happened
ready
i always believe this the like for
example a lot of women criticize why was
kevin samuel so popular all kevin
simmons was doing was revealing what men
were talking about in the barbershop so
for example if someone because most
people believe this is bs
but then it needs someone to willing to
say it and stand on it and people will
follow it and once he has a following
youtube reacts to money
so most more people said this is bs
youtube will change that algorithm
overnight alex jones got shut down and
he was massive on youtube yeah but he
didn't have the
he was huge
the momentum to do that oh you're joking
so will you use it for such a long time
david i got shut down yeah right but
david axe following us continued mm-hmm
i mean i think alex jones is doing all
right but and alex jones followers
but what i'm saying is is that
the money side of it i don't think
they're too bothered about i think it
becomes to do with like power in your
message it's like how reactionary do
people get to a tweet so if if kevin
summons a video when he was when he was
here
he's getting a hundred thousand two
hundred three hundred thousand in quick
quick time that's power in my opinion
that's influence and power yeah that's
why you want to control your position
but what i'm saying is when you're when
you have when you have power and
influence like that look at some
controversial figures that have been
taken off platforms
you mentioned a couple joseph watson
paul joseph watson
it doesn't you don't necessarily have to
chime with the message i'm a free speech
absolutist i believe you can say
whatever but
got taken off his um yeah
so but the thing is those figures paul
joseph watson he still gets his massive
numbers yeah
i'm sure still makes a ton of
he's got a ton of influence wherever he
is farrakhan still does you know
but it's i don't think it's about money
i think it's about how influential you
can be
because when you think these are kind of
like heroical figures so it's the thing
about i said i've obvious because
wow um this whole thing about
social influences
right
um that's why i don't call myself an
influencer
i call myself an opinion former
right i feel there's a difference so
people have the um the ability to form
opinions
the people that we mention that get
de-platformed
are the people that
start forming people's opinions
they're not influencers because
influencers can i don't know i'll buy a
pair of trainers oh i'll get people to
buy the trainers
it doesn't matter it's when you start to
actually start to form people's opinions
is when the quote-unquote powers that be
start to kind of look at you like who is
this person like what's going because
what did you you're shifting the tide
the one person that i actually feel like
is an opinion former right now we said
on youtube is russell brand
regardless of what you think of him i
think russell brand is forming opinions
and he's doing it in a way in which and
i commend him for this right
he's treading that line as to not
get cancelled or get de-platformed but
also give the information
do you know what i'm saying and that's a
fine line yeah well i was talking about
cancer culture
um where do we draw the line between
accountability and free speech
i i'll say this accountability if
someone's accountable but there's an
option for redemption
but wouldn't that be wouldn't that be
subjective
like for example if someone said
something wrong like what i don't like
is someone said something 10 years ago
and it's brought up and their counsel
they have like a old tweet or something
tweets and stuff like that but there's
no even if they apologize they don't get
any sort of chance to redeem themselves
and to work again that's when it crosses
the line right accountability it's like
okay you did something wrong you've
learned the lesson
you know you'll be a better person for
it council culture is you did something
wrong and we want you dead
can you always can you always measure
that though like how what does a a good
apology look like and at one point do we
forgive because you're not i'm just
gonna sit there and say okay cool if
we're just gonna say okay influencers or
whatever people yeah you come out with
your great apology lovely stuff okay
move on there's no accountability but at
the same time if we go with cancer
culture there's the other extreme where
it's like
okay well
you're just going to get cancelled
you're going to be removed no i think
there's difference in like the apology
thing do you know what i mean i think
there's like
someone today could get caught with a
racist tweet or whatever right and then
apologize my whole thing is no you know
what
when people
reveal who they are just believe them
so you're only saying uh you're saying
your apology now because you got a call
yeah yeah because behind closed doors
this is the type of stuff you say but
when it comes to that
on the flip side i believe that every
people
have race prejudice
and we're all lying about the fact that
we do
so we understand that as black people
white people asian people arab people
behind closed doors there's some stuff
that we say that we would never say in
public do you know what i'm saying like
we all know that right but the thing is
it's the honest conversation happens
when we say you know what
can i bring that out into the public and
you bring yours out into the public and
then we have a conversation about it you
know i'm saying that can we do that
that's why that's why i think racism
will consistently um rear its ugly head
because the stuff that we have behind
closed doors we're not willing to bring
out
me personally i'm wanting to bring it
out yeah i would say you know what i
think this kind of stuff sometimes can
you bring up but the thing is and i
always say that when it comes to white
people
unfortunately
they think if i bring my [ __ ] out right
i'm done i'm done i think this answers
the question of whether people can
change if you don't give people the room
to change or actually learn about your
actions that's never going to happen the
fact that we can sit down here and we a
lot of us may have different opinions on
different things and with
intersectionality being a thing we all
come from different cultures and
different and all different backgrounds
but we can sit down and we can have a
discussion and we're not afraid to
disagree with each other that's where
education comes in that's where the room
for change can come in if we're just
gonna go with cancer culture and say
okay cool you've done this wrong we can
all agree it's wrong get out leave
okay they can apologize they can write
all the best apologies in the world they
can hire writers they can hire marketing
teams whatever cool that's never going
to change like their actions or who they
are because they're not really going to
be able to see
how wrong they are
or understand where they have went wrong
and so if we actually have more
conversations and more discussions that
allows the education to take place that
allows people to see other people's
perspectives assuming they are and ask
them one question why exactly why do you
think like that and that's where why do
you feel like that
and and if people are willing to have
that conversation i feel like yeah and
sometimes you know even if you do meet
someone who's racist sometimes there's a
story behind that for example yeah why
are you yeah if someone what um
you know it's like you know
a man
his daughter was raped by a black sorry
so great by
that great by a black uh guy
could you understand why he had that
tendency
that's what we were saying earlier with
liam neeson yeah so he was in an
interview and and
he told a story about something that
happened to him
someone close to him however many years
ago and basically the lady had been
raped by somebody who was black
jesus christ
by somebody who was black and he um he i
can't remember what tool he reached
where he grabbed the tool and he was
looking for any black person to say
something wrong to him so he can sort of
carry out the scapegoat
do you know what's funny though do you
know what's interesting though about
that
and i've said
that's not something that black people
do
so if one if one of our family members
was graped by a white person we would be
like i'm gonna look for any white person
to do that
that's not something that we do